the we should return to a tradcon
history in the future is that that's
just a a dead end as far as you're
concerned well I think we need to be we
just need to be a bit more attentive to
where we are and I think we can we can
afford to be a little bit more
respectful of indiv the the Dynamics
within individual couples I mean it's it
it's generally like there are patterns
which emerge you know in any in any
given heterosexual couple you know
that's been together long term there'll
be there'll be things which are more
typical of the male partner and things
which are more typical of the female
partner and I and that's fine you know
we shouldn't be trying to fight against
those stereotypes if if they're what
works for people but I but but I don't
see much point in imposing imposing kind
of you should be doing this or you
shouldn't be doing that you know because
because ultimately you people guidelines
people do need guidelines but people you
know people work people people can
figure out what works best for them I
mean here here's one example
um so talking in very general terms I
mean I've made the argument that the
problem with tradwives as such is that
they're just not Trad enough um in the
sense that the what they're harking back
to is a sort of mid mid 20th century
template which was actually only true
for a very small subset of the middle
class and which is distinct in itself
distinctively modern because in in
premodern times all women worked pretty
apart from the the very very richest
right so you're saying the idea send it
further back agrarian grab your pesel
and mortar and hoe and get working in so
so so the question I want to ask is what
what does a 21st century version of the
premodern in productive household look
like you know the the the house where
the basic economic unit is your
household and so you you've agreed
you're all in it together you're there
for the long term you know everything
that you do you do for the team um and
then it's then it's just a matter of
agreeing of of of figuring out how how
how to get the best out of everybody and
I and I I can't I'm not interested in
legislating for any given couple what
that looks like um and in in a in a
modern context where most of us work in
the world of in the world of bits and
bites anyway I don't know I can't I
can't I can't make that determination
for you yeah um but but you but there
will be a way you know when you when you
form your household and you and you and
you make your decision about how you can
get the best out of your productive
household there'll be there'll be a
there'll be a pattern and I think
there's there's no shame in in accepting
that sometimes that can fit into a more
traditional mold what was that Insight
that you had about women needing to
develop a strategy for not having it all
well I guess that's just a variation on
talking about productive households
because I mean when again in feminism
against progress the the the analogy
I've given is weaving which I think is
it's a very it's a very powerful
illustration of what happened to to
women's work at the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution in that for for
some sort of 10 20 30,000 years prior to
the Industrial Revolution weaving was
always women's work and there very there
are solid practical reasons for that um
you can weaving is something I mean the
a household needs textiles right you
know you don't have textile factories
somebody needs to make textiles you know
you need them for clothes and you need
them for all sorts of different things
so so somebody's got to do the weaving
um and and somebody's also got to look
after the kids happily weaving and
looking after kids are fairly compatible
because you can raise a loom off the
floor um you can you can put down you
can put down your repetitive you can do
it whilst keeping an eye on you know
toddlers or small people running around
and it's interruptible and it's social
so so it's it's ideal work to be to be
getting on with while you've also got
small children under fooot and so for
for Millennia Millennia after Millennia
weaving has been women's work and but
but weaving was also one of the first
Industries to move out of the home um
into factories and at that point uh at
that point it was very it was much more
difficult for it to continue to be
women's work and you know those those
working-class women who went to work in
the textile mills had real dilemmas on
their hands because I mean what do you
meant to do with your breastfed baby you
know and there was there was there were
horror stories about you know how how
women tried tried their best to cope
with that you know babies drugged with
opium or you know left to starve or you
know you know left in the inadequate
care of yeah awful stuff and then and
then there are those women who there are
those women who who respond by just
saying okay fine we're not going to make
the textiles anymore so we're just going
to focus on on different stuff
um but but but the point is that um if
you're
if we yeah weaving is a is a fine
example of of the kind of work which
which can which in the in in premodern
times took place within a productive
household and and I suppose the question
I have is you know what kinds of work
let let's say you want to be a mom and
let's say you've got small children
around underfoot what's what what's the
equivalent work that's a bit
interruptable that's a bit social that's
a bit um you can pick it up and put it
down again that's not what people think
about when they think about have it all
though right it's I you can't have it
all come on everybody knows that well
they ought to like enough enough
feminists prior to me have have have
have leveled with the world you know you
can't have it all you know you can have
a lot
um and you can you can have a great time
doing it but you can't have it all all
of the time all at once you know you
have to do some things one after another
Louise said that she she worked it out
and she was doing 40 hours a week of
breastfeeding like a full a more than
full-time job of just that part just
that one vertical yep underneath the
child having process yeah yeah yeah and
that's not that's not something you can
Outsource because it's not it's not just
food you know there there's a whole
foundational layers of your child mother
making child making foundational aspects
of your child's capacity for
self-regulation and your child's
capacity for being being an integrated
person are laid down in those early
early interactions um it's not something
which can be subcontracted think
profoundly important this was something
that Mary eat said to me she thinks that
motherhood's a mematic desire at least
in some in some regard that um you know
one of her answers to the birth rate
declin
is
that fewer mothers beget fewer mothers I
think there's some truth in that yeah
yeah I mean if you think I'm trying to
think how many how many babies did I
ever hold before my own not very many to
be honest if any it's possible it's
possible that the first baby I ever held
was my own or if not if not the first
very certainly very close to the first
and I was in my late 30s you just think
this is crazy you know there was a not
not even that long ago there was a time
when you you'd have been you'd have been
left holding younger siblings or um
other people's kids or you'd have been
around little babies and and it wouldn't
have been frightening in the same way
but it's you know the one of the reasons
you know middle middle class older
mothers like me sit and sit there you
know with our with our our late stage
pregnancies frantically consuming baby
books is because we just don't we don't
have that we don't have that practice
around us anymore um because families
have got smaller and extended families
have got more scattered and extended
families have got smaller as well so so
the the as as Mary so eloquently
explains um in her you she writes a lot
about the the shrinking of the family
and the the atomizing effect that that
that has the loss that that imposes on
in other news this episode is brought to
you by element element is a tasty
electrolyte drink mix with everything
that you need and nothing that you don't
it's a healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks and it is the best
way that I have started my morning every
single day for over three years now it
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
with no sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system the caffeine act on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink LM
nt.com slod wisdom to get a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box plus there is a no no
questions asked refund policy so you can
buy it 100% risk-free that's drink LM
nt.com
slod wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Mary you will love the ful length
podcast which you can watch right here
go on tap it